und so backt ihr die perfekten Cupcakes
mit meinem Grundrezept denn wir lieben
alle Cupcakes in allen verschiedenen
Variationen für mein Grundrezept
verrührt ihr einfach die trockenen
Zutaten nämlich Mehl Zucker Salz und
Backpulver einfach in einer großen
Schüssel miteinander in einer separaten
Schüssel verrührt ihr dann die Eier mit
der Buttermilch und dem Sonnenblumenöl
und natürlich mit der Geheimzutat
Vanilleextrakt jetzt verrührt ihr nur
noch die trockenen und die flüssigen
Zutaten und portioniert dann am besten
mit einem Eisportionierer den Teig in
die vorbereiteten Muffinförmchen jetzt
nur noch kurz backen und fertig und die
könnt ihr jetzt nach dem Abkühlen
wunderbar weiter dekorieren